oh
look at that gold spot on the back of
the iphone 26 degrees this is hands down
the best phone for gaming of course the
iphone 13 pro and i say that for two
different reasons first of all it's got
the fastest mobile chip out there the
a15 bionic with the five core gpu and
second it's got 120 hertz pro motion for
the display technology however there is
one major issue and that is heat this
thing gets incredibly hot while playing
games especially at 120 fps like gentian
impact and pascal's wager and i came
across a very interesting video by
golden reviewer who played genji impact
at 120 fps on this phone and he said it
only lasted about 10 seconds before it
came down to 60. and because of that we
decided to buy this this is the razer
phone cooler specifically made for the
iphone because of this very special
feature check this out
max safe yes the razer phone cooler has
max save connectivity to the iphone 12
and 13 lineups which is why we decided
to buy this one because we never bought
one before but max safe is such a big
deal because it's so convenient you
don't have to clip it onto the sides or
anything bam it's on and basically the
way it works is you connect the power
cable and you flip the switch and the
fan turns on and it also has
customizable rgb lighting which you can
fully customize within the razer phone
cooler app and i do want to mention that
this is not sponsored in any way we
literally bought this because we thought
it was so cool because of that mac save
connectivity to the iphone so what i'm
going to do in this video is play a
couple games both with and without the
cooler to see if there are any
differences in fps or temps i got my
seek thermal camera right here so i'm
gonna be checking out the temps on the
back of the iphone after each gaming
session and the way i'm gonna measure
the fps is by using perf dog which
basically checks the statistics and fps
including the cpu usage memory usage
basically all the stats but namely the
fps which is what we want to see and
we're going to try to see how long it
sticks up to 120fps within those games
so without further ado i'm gonna set
this guy off to the side and i'm going
to play a 10 minute run of gentian
impact and we're going to measure the
average fps and everything else and
we're about to jump into the game and
there you go i'm going to turn on the
perf dog recording
just like that and i can show you guys
the graphics settings
go over here and you can see i've set
everything to the lowest except for 120
that i have enabled and yep i'm checking
i am hitting 120 right now in perf dog
so there you go and the reason i'm using
a cable is because you need the cable
with perf dog to hit 120 fps
so you can record and measure it
and right off the bat we've already
dropped down to 60.
it's been sticking to 60 for a little
there you go just jump back up to 120 so
i guess that's nice 115 119 there you go
not too bad so basically i'm gonna play
this for a little while and check back
in with you guys
to talk about any kind of heat or any
drops or anything like that and by the
way i started at 1 33 so at 1 43 is when
i'm gonna stop this recording all right
it's only been three minutes but i
already feel the back of the phone
getting pretty hot it's definitely
getting hot and now
let's get this guy now i'm sticking to a
pretty consistent 60 ever since i felt
that heat in the back so
it's not looking good i mean imagine you
buy this phone expecting to play games
at 120fps
and you can't it's just getting hot all
right so it's almost been 10 minutes and
man the back of the phone is really hot
but it is still jumping between 60 and
120
on that chart so not too bad but i am
seeing it now dip a little bit sometimes
even to like 57 but then it jumps back
to 120 it makes no sense honestly i
don't know why it can like it can't
fluctuate in between 120 and 60 it just
jumps straight up and down
it's kind of weird but the back of this
phone is
really really hot right now and there
you go it's been exactly 10 minutes so
i'm gonna go ahead and stop this
recording
oh and just like that i don't know if
you guys just saw that the display just
dimmed after our testing finished so wow
it dim quite a bit too i don't know if
you could tell but definitely dem so
right now i'm going to test out the heat
on the back with my thermal camera on
this iphone so let's go ahead and record
this as you guys can see we have a hot
spot right over there 43 degrees celsius
that must be where the a15 is at because
man that is hot and now it's time to put
on the razer phone cooler right in the
back as easy as that with max safe let's
flip that switch
there you go it's on and i don't know if
you guys can hear that fan
but it is pretty loud
so let's see if it's doing anything i
just got in just started recording 148
so 10 minutes from now i'm gonna stop
this measurement and testing and i can
already feel a little bit of wind from
that cooler it's working pretty well
there you go we're up to 120. oh and
even with the cooler it just dropped
down back to 60. i did not expect that
it's like i got this cooler on it's not
overheating why is it going down to 60.
it makes no sense okay there you go 120.
so it stayed up at 120 for a good amount
of time but then it jumped back down
again
it doesn't make sense like why it keeps
going back i guess the real test is
going to be when we examine the chart
right after this is done i'm going to
take a look at that chart and see if we
get a higher average fps that's going to
be the real i guess proof of this
working or not okay that was a long
stretch of 60 back to 120 again so far
guys i'm not impressed i'm looking at
this chart still staying at 60 for a
good minute man now it's back to 120
pretty decent staying at 120 oh never
mind
so it's been about six minutes and there
is a huge difference that i'm noticing
the phone is nowhere near as hot like
literally it's barely warm because of
this cooler this is actually very
surprising
and it seems to be working extremely
well however just something is wrong
with the fps like just stays at 60 for
extended periods of time even though the
phone doesn't feel
even warm so i don't know what's going
on here man this definitely feels cool
so one thing i know for sure is if you
had issues with
dimming or overheating before
you're not gonna have them right now
yeah guys it's been
almost 10 minutes
the phone feels really cool i'm
impressed all right there you go it has
been 10 minutes so i'm gonna go ahead
and
turn off the recording and with that
said let's check the temps holy moly are
you guys seeing this
look at that i got a cold spot that was
26 degrees right where the cooler was
and the hottest spot is now only 38
degrees look at that it's starting to
heat up first but it was 26 degrees
right on the back of the phone as you
can see now it's starting to warm up a
little bit
and now the hot spot is finally getting
a little bit warmer from 43
to 36 the hottest spot that is so
so impressive
this little thing let's see that
look how cold the back of the cooler is
10 degrees celsius
oh that's incredible wow like look my
table is 23
nine degrees cels eight degrees celsius
on the cooler
it is doing work and so now that we've
proven that the cooler is actually doing
a great job of lowering the temps which
is gonna stop your phone from dimming
it's gonna stop it from throttling in
certain games let's actually look at the
fps charts right here on
perfdog.wetest.net i have both of them
open side by side and without the cooler
playing genjin for about 10 minutes we
averaged 75.6 fps
and going down to the cpu usage 18.7
average so essentially we have 75.6 and
now let's go over to
the cooler gaming session
77.6 fps
exactly 2 fps higher
after getting
this razer phone cooler which is
definitely disappointing and i honestly
think that there's something wrong with
how it handles 120 fps gaming because it
was noticeably more cool and going down
to cpu up look at that 19.9 percent so i
guess it was throttling less because the
average cpu usage
is higher and maybe that's where we're
getting the extra 2fps average but man
that is not what i was expecting
especially with those thermal
differences and i do want to mention
that without the cooler after about 10
minutes the display did actually dim
down which would lead to a much worse
gaming experience compared to with the
cooler it was staying cool and there was
no dimming in sight which that is
definitely a benefit even if you're not
getting that much better fps man these
results are so disappointing because i
don't think it's doing the 120fps
properly so i was actually just going to
play this game but i think i'm going to
test out one more game that supports 120
fps and i'm gonna see if we get a better
advantage there and now let's jump into
pascal's wager which as you can see has
120 fps support right there so
we're gonna go ahead and jump into the
game and with that said let's hit record
232 so at 2
42 will be done all right right off the
bat we're having the same issue
60 fps does not want to go up to 120
really weird oh there you go once again
i'm feeling this heat up so whoa i think
i just saw the display dim i don't know
if you guys noticed that but
i think the display just dimmed it's
been about five minutes in oh
it just dimmed like mad you guys seen
this
i can almost like not even see this
display
what is going on insanely hot on the
back of this thing all right there you
go it's been 10 minutes so let's go
ahead and turn off
this fps recording
just like that and now it's time to
check the taps all right this is the
moment of truth
flip it over what do we got 43 44
degrees celsius right there on the back
look even the table where it was
is warm
43 degrees celsius just like before even
one up to 44 at times
you could definitely see a little circle
right there
of heat where those max safe magnets are
44 degrees man that's hot and with that
said let's go ahead toss on the razer
cooler
just like that mac safe super convenient
turn it on and let's hit record 246 so
10 minutes from now right still sticking
to us pretty good 120 it's actually
impressive i wonder if it's based off
like the the location or something i
don't know but so it's been staying at a
pretty good 120 this time interestingly
phone still feels very cool compared to
without the cooler man it gets so hot
alrighty there you go it's been 10
minutes with the razor cooler let's go
ahead and pause that and let's check the
temps all right guys moment of truth
let's pop it off
move it over flip it oh
look at that gold spot on the back of
the iphone 26 degrees
are you kidding me did you see that cold
spot and as far as the hottest point
only 36
degrees celsius on the iphone just like
last time compared to 44 without this
razor cooler this is super super
impressive
once again look at that 11 to 10 degrees
celsius on the like dude this thing's
cold it is legit
like gold so with that said let's go
ahead and look at the charts for
pascal's wager all right and here we are
on the perf dog website this is the 10
minute run without the cooler we're
looking at an average fps of
90.7 cp usage at 11.9 percent so 90.7
and here's the moment of truth how much
fps did we get with the razer phone
cooler this is 60 bucks it's pretty
expensive but let's see if it's worth it
a hundred average fps hey that is an
improvement man
100 average from the 90 it's not that
big of a difference but the difference
in the cooling alone is incredible
because with the first 10 minute run
without the cooler
the display dimmed multiple times and at
one point it got so dim that you could
hardly see the game
and that's very important with this kind
of game because it's pretty dark itself
naturally so
lots of dimming lots of overheating but
with the cooler man it was staying so
cool instead of 44 degrees celsius the
hottest point on the back it was at 36
and you guys saw that blue cool spot
wow that is incredible i've got to say
this thing is nice because first of all
mac safe
you can't beat mac safe it just pops on
you don't need to crimp it on with any
kind of holders on the edge nothing
literally this is so convenient so i'd
say if you're gonna buy any phone cooler
out there
this one is the one to buy for the
iphone 12 series or the iphone 13 series
because of that max safe and as you guys
saw we actually got some pretty decent
results so i've got to say that if
you're a mobile gamer and you're
suffering from display dimming or
overheating of any kind
you've got to get this thing this is
probably the best phone cooler because
of the max a feature so if you enjoyed
this video definitely check out the
links below to the razer phone cooler if
you want to check this out and buy one
for yourself and hopefully you enjoyed
this video if you did go ahead click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]